Вероніка Черевичко втратила ногу через обстріл, який відбувся, коли жінка сиділа на дитячому майданчику біля свого будинку.
А це - зруйнований будинок Валентини Ткаченко.
Вона втратила не лише житло, а й чоловіка, який загинув внаслідок обстрілу.
На цьому відео - Олександр Мельник, він відвідує могилу свого брата Костянтина, який помер від осколків снаряда.
Цих мешканців Харкова об'єднує те, що вони постраждали від касетних бомб, які, ймовірно, застосовує російська армія.
Цей вид озброєння заборонений Конвенцією ООН щодо касетних боєприпасів від 2008 року.
Як роз'яснює міжнародна організація Human Rights Watch, небезпека касетних бомб полягає в тому,
що вони містять десятки або сотні суббоєприпасів.
Ті розлітаються на більшу площу, зазвичай розміром з футбольне поле.
Темі використання касетних боєприпасів в Україні присвячена доповідь Amnesty International під назвою "ANYONE CAN DIE AT ANY TIME":
"Кожен може померти у будь-який час".
Назва має на увазі надзвичайну небезпеку цього виду озброєння.
Ми виявили, що російські війська в ході безжальних обстрілів Харкова завдали невибіркових ударів,
внаслідок яких загинули сотні людей і тисячі отримали поранення.
Багатьох ударів завдали зі застосуванням касетних боєприпасів, які заборонені для широкого використання,
а також іншої зброї невибіркової дії, такої як артилерійські снаряди, ракети та наземні міни.
Це призводить до загибелі та поранення цивільного населення, руйнування цивільних об'єктів.
При цьому експерти Amnesty вважають: касетне озброєння використовують обидві сторони і Росія, і Україна.
Багато країн, зокрема такі великі як США, Китай, Індія та ж Росія, не підписали конвенцію про заборону цієї зброї.
Є такі країни і в ЄС: Фінляндія вважає цю зброю необхідною для самозахисту у разі нападу на неї.
Утім, проблема ще й у тому, як саме Росія використовує це касетне озброєння в Україні, пояснюють експерти.
Ми бачимо з російського боку навмисне застосування касетного озброєння проти цивільних.
Обстрілюють населені пункти, місця роздачі гуманітарної допомоги, коридори для біженців.
І це, звісно, очевидний воєнний злочин.
Але це було б злочином і тоді,  якби ті ж обстріли велися з іншого типу зброї.
Розслідування New York Times проаналізувало понад 450 випадків, коли в Україні було виявлено зброю РФ,
й ідентифікувало використання російськими військовими понад 2000 боєприпасів,
переважна більшість з яких були зброєю невибіркової дії.
Понад 210 видів були широко заборонені міжнародними договорами. Усі, крім кількох, були касетними боєприпасами.
Дослідники й журналісти зазначають, що використання цих видів зброї Росією не було обмеженим або поодиноким.
Фактично, це стало основою стратегії війни РФ від початку вторгнення.
До речі, саме таку зброю російські війська також масово використовували в Сирії.
Існує ще одна проблема касетного озброєння.
Більше половини бомб не розриваються під час падіння і перетворюються на міни,
які стають смертельною небезпекою для мирних мешканців упродовж наступних десятиліть.
Під час запуску ракети касетні бомби вводяться в бойове положення і залишаються в ньому.
Проблема виникає саме тоді, коли вони потрапляють у м'який ландшафт,
який ускладнює їхню звичайну детонацію, що відбувається при ударі.
Далі вони лежать у цьому ландшафті та починають іржавіти.
Це тривалий механічний процес. В результаті бомби можуть стати непридатними.
А може вийти так, що стіни снаряда стануть настільки тонкими, що найменший дотик призведе до детонації.
І тоді достатньо, щоб по ньому проїхав велосипед або його взяла до рук дитина, щоб погратися.
Під час війни у В'єтнамі в 1970-х роках США скинули мільйони таких бомб на Лаос,
зробивши його найзабрудненішою країною у світі.
Аж до сьогодні касетні бомби стають причиною травм та загибелі людей у Лаосі.
А деякі райони цієї країни все ще залишаються непридатними для життя.